The portal is a project of Shared
Studios which is a nonprofit and they
have portals all around the world, so
today we're connecting with Amman, Jordan
and there is a very large Syrian refugee
population near where this portal is
located there. My students have been
studying the Syrian conflict
particularly and it's wonderful they
have the portal here for our students
and our faculty and staff and people
from around the university to have an
opportunity to interact with people live
and in-person.
full-body experience.
We are from Jordan. And she is Muffa, and this is Yousseff.
I see. How was your day today?
I just got out of the portal and we were ending the talk, I was
facilitating for most of the afternoon
and one of the gentlemen mentioned this
young girl, fifteen years old had a
beautiful voice he and she was very
soft-spoken throughout the entire
interaction and then started singing and
it was gorgeous.
I'm like tearing up just
thinking of what just happened. She sang
a song in the other line in Arabic and
she said it was about love and longing
and it was beautiful, and the song I
usually sing, I'm Catholic, and so I sing
Ave Maria, which is one of my favorite
songs so it was just such a beautiful,
spiritual experience and just really
vulnerable; on the other end of the world
you're sharing this really intimate part
of you; here you are singing this song
that means so much to me and I could
tell the song meant so much to her and
it was just a connection I quite frankly
really haven't had in a long time, it was
just so beautiful.
In my conversations with many different
families in the internally displaced
persons camp in Erbil, Iraq, they said
please just tell our stories let people
know about who we are and help people to
understand both the challenges we're
facing but also our resilience and the
fact that we are able not only to
survive the challenges we're facing but
that we look to the future with great
hope and great aspiration.